notre invité politique ce matin c'est le
maire de nice christian estrosi et
bonjour aux questions estrosi bonjour
alors nous sommes ensemble pour un
entretien de 20 minutes en partenariat
avec la presse quotidienne régionale qui
est représenté aujourd'hui par nice
matin
nous sommes à distance avec denis carot
le directeur des rédactions du groupe
nice matin bonjour denis
bonjour à tous alors oui on va commencer
par parler de la crise sanitaire
christian estrosi puisque le territoire
ni ce soit est un des territoires les
plus touchés par l'épidémie ces derniers
mois est ce que le virus recul à nice
il recule très fortement puisque nous
avons été sans doute un des tout
premiers au début de l'année à atteindre
un pic important à 702 taux d'incidence
de circulation du virus est que nous
sommes aujourd'hui sans doute la
métropole où le taux d'incidence de
circulation du virus est le plus bas
hier soir 198 nous sommes à 5,8 de taux
de positivité 7 5,8 pour cent c'est un
des taux les plus bas de france et pour
la première fois depuis début janvier
nous avons moins de 300 hospitalisations
ce sont donc des signes très
encourageants mais qui exigent même
temps que nous restions très rigoureux
très ferme sur les mesures de protocole
sanitaire de mesures barrières et que
nous continuons à accélérer notre
campagne de vaccination qui sans doute y
est pour beaucoup puisque la moyenne de
vaccination sur le département et plus
particulièrement sur le métropole de
nice est aujourd'hui de 29 5% on va
passer les 30% d'ici la fin de la
semaine là où la moyenne nationale je
vous le rappelle est à 16,8 pour cent
alors justement on va en parler de cette
vaccination avec une question de deniers
oui justement christian estrosi vous
avez prévu de vacciner dix mille
personnes dans les deux prochains jours
est ce que cela veut dire que le rythme
de fourniture des doses de vaccin
s'accélère
où il d'abord aujourd'hui nous avons un
rythme qui progressivement chaque
semaine augmente c'est alors on nous dit
mais pourquoi avez-vous autant de
vaccins qui vous sont fournis je crois
que c'est un témoignage de confiance de
la part du ministre de la santé et du
gouvernement par rapport aux aux
conditions d'organisation et la
logistique que nous avons mises en place
nous voyons qu'il y a des territoires où
on adresse des doses de vaccination de
manière conséquente mais qui ne
réussissent pas toujours à remplir le
quota nous depuis le début on l'a
systématiquement remplies a jamais eu
une dose de laisser de côté ce qui nous
permet aujourd'hui d'avoir cette
logistique très forte
nous pourrions si nous les recevrons
aujourd'hui administrait 50000 vaccins
par semaine le fameux week-end booster
on en effet treize mille dans le
week-end ça démontre bien que ce niveau
des 50000 serait atteignable si nous
avions les doses nécessaires alors à
nice et un très grand vaccinodromes et
il ya eu des images en plus inquiétante
ce week-end et notamment samedi 4012
astrazeneca dans le lac cynodrome
seulement quelques dizaines de personnes
vaccinées
qu'est ce qui s'est passé tout
simplement nous n'avons pas vocation à
faire de l'astra est née cas où le savez
très bien les directives
gouvernementales celle astrazeneca pour
les pharmaciens et pour les médecins
généralistes et pourquoi at on confié à
des collectivités comme la nôtre de
faire le faiseur le modern a jusqu ici
c'est parce que ce sont des vaccins qui
ne sont conservable cas moins 80 degrés
le minimum donc pour la première fois
l'état a demandé à ce qu'on pouvait
puisse utiliser et mettre en oeuvre las
razones et cas là où les gens sont
habitués dans les relations avec notre
plateforme métropolitaine l'inscription
nerfs sur le kaiser et ils n'y ont pas
été favorables et nous reprenons le
cours normal de ce que nous faisions les
semaines précédentes dès cette semaine
comme vient de le rappeler denis carot
est justement une question denis carot
sur le vaccin russe le vaccin skotnik
alors christian estrosi vous aviez
annoncé fin mars avoir fait des pré
commandes de vaccins ce pouce postic
vais vous en êtes où aujourd'hui est-ce
que ce vaccin peut arriver dans les
semaines prochaines
dans la métropole niçoise oui absolument
je ne doute pas que les autorités
sanitaires européennes et françaises
valley d'ici la fin du mois de juin le
spoutnik nous savons que c'est par la
campagne de vaccination qui montre en
puissance que nous gagnerons en immunité
le plus rapidement possible dans notre
pays
il se trouve que il y a des règles selon
lesquelles tout ce qui est commandée par
l'union européenne ne peut pas être
commandée par quelqu'un d'autre
donc par exemple je ne pourrais pas
passer de commandes dit de pfizer ni de
mode hernani d'astrazeneca ni de johnson
& johnson
mais l'union européenne n'a pas commandé
de spoutnik donc j'ai pris des
dispositions aujourd'hui j'ai même
acoyer du gouvernement russe qui
garantit de me faire une livraison de
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de doses
spoutnik dès lors que l'autorité
sanitaire aura admis que nous puissions
en faire disposé l'ensemble de nos
administrés non dès l'autorisation
sanitaires ont combien de temps vous
aurez ces doses de vaccin russe en
quelques jours deux jours trois jours
quatre jours aujourd'hui les choses sont
on sont prêtes
j'avais dit vous savez au mois de mars
2020 alors qu'on prétendait que le
masque était inutile aujourd'hui nous
parlons sur votre plateau avec un masque
à l'époque on disait c'est est il utile
j'avais commandé pour près de 50 tonnes
de matériel sur plusieurs continents et
notamment en asie et affréter des avions
cargos pour ça et puis quelques semaines
plus tard alors que nous en avions
distribué près de 2 millions à la
population de la métropole est
intervenue cette décision selon laquelle
le masque était devenue indispensable
donc voilà aujourd'hui l'agilité d'une
collectivité qui illustre que nous avons
de nouveaux métiers qui se sont mis en
place au cours de cette année puisque
j'ai bâti une agence de sécurité
sanitaire environnementale et de gestion
des risques qui nous permet d'être
réactif d'être agile d'être flexible
pour nous adapter mieux répondre à
toutes ces situations sanitaires comme à
d'autres situations qu'elles nous
pourrions être confrontés en matière
d'intempéries de terrorisme de séisme ou
je ne sais quelle situation laquelle il
faudrait faire face c'est ce qui fait la
force d'une collectivité c'est ce qui
doit inciter l'état à aller vers plus de
décentralisation alors on va parler du
déconfinement et de la réouverture de
certains lieux durant le mois de mai
notamment des terrasses des bars et des
restaurants
christian estrosi comment vous préparez
à ceux des confinement à cette
réouverture de certains lieux et bien
nous mettons place d'ores et déjà en
relation avec nos professionnels de
l'hôtellerie de la restauration du
commerce
un protocole sanitaire je m'en suis
entretenu hier avec olivier ferrand il
se trouve que de manière très volontaire
nous avons été un le premier territoire
de france confiné pourquoi parce que
arriver les vacances d'hiver j'ai vu ce
que les vacances de fin d'année 2020 et
de jour de l'an avait provoqué d'afflux
de touristes qui pour beaucoup à cause
d'une monte en puissance de vol de
provenances anglo saxon scandinave des
émirats sur l'aéroport international de
nice a amené le variant britannique chez
nous et nous a fait monter un pic
important et donc pour être sûr que
vacances d'hiver alors qu'on commençait
à faire baisser la tension
nous n'ayons pas de nouveau une remontée
en puissance
je me suis dit qu'il valait mieux
obtenir un confinement le week-end donc
cette rigueur nous l'avons mise en place
on a été les premiers confiné que nous
soyons les premiers des confiné dès lors
qu en tenant bon la même rigueur dans
les jours les 15 jours qui viennent nous
ayons encore notre courbe qui continuent
à descendre de manière rapide et bien je
suis en train de proposer au ministre de
la santé
un autre protocole sanità près strictes
notamment des autotests chez les
restaurateurs
où nous pourrions faire une première
expérimentation sur une cinquantaine
d'entre eux avec des ouvertures sur les
espaces publics où on va piétonniser
provisoirement dans un premier temps un
certain nombre d' espaces publics pour
pouvoir servir en extérieur la même
chose pour la culture théâtre l'opéra le
cinéma et les musées un certificat de
vaccination un petit carnet que nous
commençons après edith et où il y aura à
la fois où la certification d'une
vaccination ou d'un test pcr de moins de
72 heures pour pouvoir accéder à une
activité avec un qr code pour être sûr
qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un faux et
d'autres mesures complémentaires et à
partir de ce protocole que nous allons
proposer nous espérons pouvoir être
parmi les premiers des confiné et mettre
en oeuvre ces dispositions dans la
première quinzaine du mois de mai par
exemple des confinement qui va faire du
bien à certains secteurs tous très
touchés des secteurs touristiques
notamment sur le territoire niçois et on
va parler du plan de relance denis carot
oui vous avez signé la semaine dernière
jeudi dernier avec jean castex le plan
de relance et de transition écologique
delà de la métropole c'est une enveloppe
au total de deux milliards et demi
d'euros
est-ce que ce plan de relance vous
satisfait et d'une certaine manière est
ce que vous estimez qu'il est exemplaire
des rapports entre l'état et les
collectivités locales
en tout cas dans ce domaine je dirais
qu'il est totalement exemplaire puisque
d'abord l'état français on peut
reprocher beaucoup de choses au
gouvernement mais enfin le gouvernement
misait d'abord sur le soutien par
l'économie et des soutiens financiers
très importants à nos activités pour
qu'elle ne meure pas chômage partiel et
soutien aux loyers
et lorsque l'on regarde chez nos voisins
européens
ce type de mesures n'ont pas été prises
mais ce qu'il faut c'est essayer de
faire en sorte que la relance soit une
chance pour les territoires je pense que
ça peut même être une opportunité de
rebondir encore plus haut que ce que
nous étions avant la crise en négociant
100 milliards d'euros 68 hier pour
l'état français 40 milliards pour
l'union européenne
j'ai souhaité que la métropole de nice
côte d'azur soit candidate tout de suite
puisque nous avions des dossiers qui
étaient prêts pour rentrer dans les
trois volets de ce plan de relance
la cohésion sociale la compétitivité et
surtout la transition écologique parce
que nous rentrions non ces critères nous
avons eu de multiples réunions
interministérielles
nous avons signé avec jean castex à
matignon jeudi dernier ce contrat de
relance pour deux milliards et demi à
consommer dans les deux ans ou être
engagés dans les trois ans ça va être un
formidable accélérateur de tous nos
projets sans doute certains projets
qu'il aurait fallu mettre sept ans à
réaliser pourront l'être en moins de 3 4
ans c'est donc pour les entreprises
c'est donc pour les salariés
vous savez lorsque l'on dit que 1
milliard d'euros d'investis ça
représente à peu près dix mille emplois
on s team pour notre part que ce plan de
relance soutiendra et créera près de
25000 emplois 38 l'emploi christian
estrosi on a parlé de justice et de
sécurité puisque hier le premier
ministre jean castex a dévoilé son plan
de création de 8000 places de prison
supplémentaires pour atteindre la
promesse du président de la république
de créer quinze mille places de prison
au total ça va dans le bon sens oui ça
va dans le bon sens nous il ya ma 7500
chantier aujourd'hui le garde des sceaux
s'est engagé sur 15000 places de prison
nous avons besoin d'augmenter la
capacité carcérale de notre pays
donc c'est une bonne orientation
beaucoup d'annoncés sur la sécurité
ces derniers jours notamment de la part
du président de la république sur les
moyens des forces de l'ordre on va en
parler avec denis carot à l'écart ces
créations de postes dans les forces de
l'ordre ça concert de nice également ça
concerne eunice simplement une question
complémentaire sur le plan pénitentiaire
qui a été choisie présenté hier il n'est
pas question de nice et certains élus
notamment le député la république en
marche cédric roussel explique que si le
dossier de la prison de nice n'avance
pas c'est que les élus locaux ne se
mettent pas d'accord
christian estrosi où en est ce dossier
de la prison de nice ce député de la
république en marche fort et mieux de
proposer lui-même à quel endroit de sa
circonscription il verrait bien
l'implantation d'une prison plutôt que
de critiquer les élus locaux
ça démontre bien le décalage qu'il y a
quelques fois entre les parlementaires
qui sont peu tôt fait avec le terrain
nous avons vous le savez denis carot
puisque vous l'avez commenté dans
nice-matin passé avec le maire de grasse
jérôme viaud avec le député eric ciotti
très engagé sur ces dossiers une
proposition pour qu'il y est une grande
extension de l'hôpital de grasse ton
corner parfaitement d'accord pour
l'heure elle n'a pas été retenue
et vous savez que
moi même j'ai fait un certain nombre de
propositions sur la métropole de nice et
sur nice même qui pour l'instant ne sont
pas retenus je dis bien pour l'instant
car là aussi c'est un dossier qui doit
toucher à la décentralisation jeudi que
trop souvent les administrations
centrales pèse sur les décisions des
ministres
là où au fond nous sommes les mieux
placés pour savoir où doit être
positionné un ensemble carcéral et
aujourd'hui je fais plancher mes
ingénieurs mais juriste mais aménageurs
du territoire pour faire des
propositions au ministère de la justice
qui démontre que nous avons des
spécialistes d'aménagement du territoire
et de sécurité qui sont tout aussi
compétent si ce n'est plus quelques fois
que ceux qui sont dans les grandes
administrations centrales décentralisée
moi en me donnant les moyens financiers
nécessaires et en respectant les règles
administratives et juridiques
nécessaires sur ce que doit être un
univers carcéral et nous bâtirons à ce
moment là là où il le faut
la prison de nice j'assume totalement
mes responsabilités parlons des forces
de l'ordre puisque emmanuel macron
annoncé qu'ils allaient tenir son
objectif de créer dix mille postes de
policiers et de gendarmes sur le
quinquennat avec des annonces de postes
supplémentaires et notamment 22 postes
de policiers a nice c'est suffisant
c'est pas 22 postes
c'est un accord passé au mois de juillet
dernier lorsque après des années où sous
les gouvernements de françois hollande
j'ai dénoncé la montée en puissance de
certains points de trafic de drogue sans
qu'il n'y ait la moindre réaction
nous avons eu enfin avec le président de
la république avec le premier ministre
dès 2010 est un engagement de l'état sur
l'ancien hôpital de nice saint roch que
j'avais racheté pour y faire un grand
hôtel de police mutualisé police
nationale police municipale pour en
faire un lieu d'expérimentation pour
l'état qui pourrait se reproduire sur
d'autres collectivités en france et il
se trouve que au mois de juillet dernier
le premier ministre après qu'il y ait eu
des incidents majeurs sur fond de trafic
de drogue est venu sur place que nous
avons eues à un accord entre l'état et
la collectivité où j'ai dit chaque fois
que vous nous apporterez à policier
national qui fait défaut à nos effectifs
il manquait à peu près 100 policiers
nationaux sur les effectifs qui devaient
être affectés à notre ville eh bien je
recrute un policier municipal de plus un
plus un ça fait deux nous sommes sur ces
100 policiers à 60 qui sont arrivés en
septembre 22 qui viennent d'être
accordés en plus ça fait 82 18 qui
arriveront prochainement et en même
temps nous progressons dans le
recrutement de nos policiers municipaux
c'est à dire que ce bon accord entre
l'état et la collectivité apportera sur
à peu près deux années près de 200
policiers de plus entre l'état et la
police municipale de nice
c'est du gagnant gagnant au silence
c'est du gagnant gagnant avec je le dis
au passage sur l'hôtel de police le
projet qui annonce puisque dans le plan
de relance qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure
avec denis carreaux et il y à 250
millions d'euros d'engagement de l'état
là où nous sommes propriétaires du
bâtiment pour faire tous les travaux
d'aménagement alors il nous reste
quelques minutes denis car on va parler
des élections régionales
oui les élections régionales vous aviez
été mus christian estrosi président de
la région décembre 2015 face à marion
maréchal-le pen
quelle est la stratégie aujourd'hui pour
l'actuel président renaud muselier ne
s'est pas encore déclarée en revanche
sophie cluzel s'est déclaré et qu'on
verra une liste de la de la majorité la
république en marche
quelle est la bonne la bonne stratégie
d'abord vous savez que je n'aime pas
trop parler de campagne électorale et
des élections à un moment où les
français n'y sont pas du tout et ce
matin je suis sûr que c'est peut-être le
moment où il se débranche de public
sénat
là où jusqu'à présent nous avons parlé
de ré sujets qui les concernent
c'est à dire la santé les protéger
investir la relance économique
vous croyez qu'en ce moment ils ont le
coeur à ça voilà pourquoi je disais ne
rentrons pas dans une campagne
électorale
tant que nous n'avons pas fini la
campagne vaccinale
car tant que nous n'aurons pas une
immunité globale dans notre pays je
pense que devancé les échéances alors
qu'elles ne sont pas confinés elle
pourrait avoir lieu en 2021 mais c'est
comme ça la date du mois de juin a été
ré la technique il va bien falloir aller
dans ces élections et nous voyons
qu'avec
mon élection en 2015 après 18 ans de
gestion socialistes communistes verts de
la région et nous avons avec renaud
muselier qui a pris ma succession permis
à cette région aujourd'hui d'être aux
côtés de chaque collectivité la région
elle-même a signé un contrat de plan sur
cinq ans avec le premier ministre à
toulon j'étais à ses côtés extrêmement
ambitieux dans le domaine et transporte
dans le domaine de l'université dans le
domaine de la formation dans le domaine
de la transition écologique
donc voilà nous avons aujourd'hui un
président sortant
un partenariat avec l'état qui était
extrêmement ambitieux ça veut dire que
le gouvernement reconnaît la pertinence
de notre bilan et s'engage sur un projet
d'avenir
je dis qu'à partir de là dépassons les
problèmes de clivages partisans
c'est bien parce qu'il y avait eu un
moment à un regroupement de toutes les
forces républicaines pour barrer la
route à à marion maréchal-le pen en 2015
avec mon élection que nous avons réussi
à remettre sur pied la région sud avec
renaud muselier et bien puisque tout le
monde se reconnaît aujourd'hui sur le
bilan de renaud muselier puisque
aujourd'hui tout le monde est d'accord
sur un projet de relance avec les
métropoles de toulon hubert falco de
nice et moi même que marseille est en
grande difficulté économique et qu'il va
falloir même si ceux qui la dirigent
aujourd'hui ne sont pas forcément des
amis mais les marseillais ne doivent pas
être laissés pour compte il faut les
accompagner et accompagner la
municipalité en place et bien mettons
nos oeufs dans le même panier toutes les
énergies toute la force nécessaire
apportant des réponses sanitaire
apportons des réponses économiques
apportons des réponses sociales et
dépassons les clivages partisans
donc il faut une colline une coalition
entre renaud muselier sophie cluzel dès
le premier tour mais
et attendez il ya un président sortant
c'est renaud muselier aujourd'hui où on
lui fait confiance on lui fait pas
confiance et aujourd'hui je vois que des
gens de tous horizons plutôt très
majoritairement envie de faire confiance
à renaud muselier cas une division qui
viendrait d'ailleurs la division et
mortifère pourrait avoir des
conséquences économiques et sociales
considérables sur l'emploi sur
l'environnement sur la gestion sanitaire
d'une situation comme celle que nous
connaissons ou d'autres qui pourrait
venir et donc ne prenons pas de risques
inutiles
montrons que nous sommes la région de la
raison tout en étant une région de
passion entre la méditerranée et les
alpes ça fait partie de notre
tempérament ou la diversité les uns et
des autres lorsqu elle est respectueuse
de grandes valeurs républicaines peu
s'additionner donc en quelques mots vous
êtes plutôt pour cette alliance de la
droite avec la majorité présidentielle
aux régionales mais je suis pour que
toutes les compétences ou savez pour moi
d'abord les gens qui viennent de la
société civile qui affichent des valeurs
gaullistes comme je peux les affiches et
du centre
les libéraux tout comme jacques chirac
avec l'ump l'union pour la majorité
présidentielle en 2001 qui a porté une
forte période de prospérité à notre pays
et bien c'est cette vision qu'il nous
faut avoir aujourd'hui et une dernière
question rapidement sur la
présidentielle
est ce qu'il faut là aussi une coalition
entre la droite et emmanuel macron dès
le premier tour je vous redis
aujourd'hui que les français ne sont pas
dans les campagnes électorales et
qu'aujourd'hui faire de la politique
partisane qui les contrarient ray n'est
pas dans mon tempérament je suis en
représentants des territoires je conduis
aussi une petite formation politique
avec près de 300 maires dans l'autre
pays qui s'appelle la france audacieuse
on est dans l'audace on est dans les
initiatives
nous sommes pour une prof forte lois de
décentralisation aujourd'hui que le
gouvernement et la majorité nous
démontre aussi cette volonté là où je
vois un texte bien trop timide qui se
profile devant le parlement en direction
des territoires et il est temps qu'on
fasse confiance au territoire
et lorsque nous aurons franchi toutes
ces étapes pour savoir qui est le mieux
placé pour répondre aux territoires de
france je répondre à votre question
eh bien on vous réinvite rassure ce
plateau merci beaucoup crise christian
estrosi d'avoir été notre invité
politique ce matin demain à votre place
ce sera à mes lignes challe 1 la
ministre de la transformation et de la
fonction publique
merci beaucoup denis carot d'avoir co
interio et christian estrosi denis carot
vous êtes directeur des rédactions du
groupe nice matin et on va regarder la
une de nice matin consacrée aux langues
régionales le niçois a un avenir
la langue niçoise le nice le nisar un
avenir issa nissa ont fini par ces mots
merci beaucoup christian estrosi
[Musique]